he's an athlete actor and entrepreneur
he's considered to be one of the
greatest if not the single greatest
basketball player of all time he's worth
over a billion dollars and his brain
grosses over two point two five billion
dollars every year he's Michael Jordan
and here are his top ten rules for
success every day the first person there
before the Sun would be Jordan and he
was there because he wasn't good he
would work with a batting instructor and
work all day long and be the last person
to leave every night also system what it
was like for him the morning and Jordan
said I get up before the Sun comes up
and I make myself some breakfast by
myself he was down there alone and I get
in the car and I'm driving to spring
training and there's no one really out
on the roads yet and I look at the seat
next to me and I see my dad and I talked
to him I think to myself pops for doing
this we're doing this together and the
day would end and he would say to the
batting instructor can we do a little
more I think I'm getting this I think
I'm learning this I think I'm
and that's when Sports Illustrated put
him on the cover saying that Michael
Jordan is embarrassed baseball and as I
would watch him there every night as the
Sun was going down on the other ball
players have left and I would see this
guy working to get better Michael Jordan
working to get better I couldn't help
thinking that if you ever have children
you ought to pray that they grew up
someday when they're she liked this play
professional basketball for the Chicago
Bulls 32 seconds to go I want point lead
for Georgetown Rd the block the time
Joey
tried to trace my evolution and I'm the
Michael Jordan revolution that always
had to start back in college hitting a
shot against Georgetown in 1982 and I
really didn't know exactly what I was
doing
it awakened a person inside of me to
excel to compete to excel to be one of
the best obv bears that joke and I guess
with that shot it kind of knotted a fire
inside an infinity
nothing was going to stop
I wanted to excel my game and isolate my
game from everybody else that I was more
than just you know a few dimensional
even when it came to Magic Johnson I
mean Magic Johnson was it your
crowd-pleaser he was a good offensive
player he was a great motivator you know
average defensive player you know I
wanted to change that I wouldn't take
another step I want to do all those
things you know that it could separate
me from Magic Johnson you know I'm not
saying he wasn't great he still is great
but we're great in our own different way
you know and that was motivational for
me you know and to this day still lives
I miss more than 9,000 shots in my
career
I've lost almost 300 games 26 times I've
been trusted to take the game-winning
shot and missed have failed over and
over and over again in my life
and that is why I succeed I never feel
that I'm at my best I feel I still have
room to improve still set goals for
myself to strive for
I'm never complacent with what I've
achieved even though it's been very
successful for me I still feel I have a
lot to prove not just as a player but as
a person as a father to some extent as a
role model in all aspects so I'm never
really too complacent with myself or
with what I've achieved when I get to a
point where I feel I can't improve as a
player I'll walk away from the game I'm
still feel that I have a plateau that
you know I hadn't reached yet in terms
of my skills all my expectations of
myself you know I'm always going to
expect myself to do certain things or
surpass certain things as long as I
believe that then you know my road to
success is can continue to expand the
sports user is it's a tool that teaches
you know and it teaches you bad things
it can also teach you good things it's
how you perceive those things I've
looked at every experience that I've had
negative and positive and taking that as
a positive you know if I wouldn't change
anything because I think it would alter
some of the other things that happen you
know so when I look back I can't say
that I've had any bad things happen sure
I mean you don't want bad things happen
but you deal with bad things you can't
have good or and without bad it's not
about two shoes
it's about knowing where you going
not forgetting where you started it's
about having the courage to fail
not breaking when you're broken taking
everything you've been given and making
something better
it's about work
before glory
and what's inside of you
what they say you can
is not about the shoes
it's about what you do in there
it's about being we were born to be
we are old and sure retire it's been a
long season but mentally we have a we
have a vision we have a finish that we
have to attain you know and sometimes
you have to do it when you old and
you're tired you know and I think it's
the test of your will to succeed when
you have to deal with some of these
negatives and I'm pretty sure by the end
of this playoffs you see the old and the
tired people were very very young and
strong mentally maybe it's my own fault
maybe I led you to believe it was easy
when it wasn't maybe I made you think my
highlight started at the free-throw line
and not in the gym maybe I made you
think that every shot I took was a
game-winner
if my game was built on flash and not
fire
maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
that failure gave me strength that my
pain was my motivation
maybe I led you to believe the
basketball with a guy given gift and not
something I work for every single day of
my life
maybe I destroy the game
oh maybe you just make an excuse it the
basket with it unbelievable 13 seconds
left Jordan left side my practice is if
I'm playing the game so when the moment
comes in the game it's not new to me
that's the beauty of the game of
basketball that's the reason why you
practice that's the effort so when you
get to that moment you don't have to
think instinctively things happen your
drive
and fire
the Bulls lead 8786 Michael Jordan with
45 points yes yeah I think it was a very
defining moment of what my career was in
Chicago the Chicago Bulls have won their
sixth NBA championship that's the last
image of Michael Jordan how magnificent
is it thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Renato asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Jordans
top 10 rules you like the most let me
know in the comments I'm going to join
the discussion thank you for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon